We know this equation produces an ellipse. We start at the center at the origin
0, 0, and then we move two units left and right in the x direction, and then we
move three units in the y direction, up and down. This gives us four main
points on our ellipse so that way we can graph it easily. We're going to use
this knowledge of ellipses to help us graph a hyperbola. A hyperbola is another
type of conic section and its equation looks more like this. Notice that the
difference between a hyperbola equation and an ellipse equation is this
subtraction sign here. For ellipses, we have addition between the x squared
term and the y squared term. But for hyperbolas, we have subtraction between
the terms. One is positive and one is negative. To graph this hyperbola, we're
going to start by graphing it as an ellipse. So we'll start with this shape
that we already have. Now, those first four points were helpful for graphing
the start of our elipse and they're also going to be helpful for graphing our
hyperbola. We'll draw a dashed rectangle around our ellipse so that way we can
start graphing our hyperbola. Once we have the rectangle, we'll draw dash lines
across the diagonals. Now, this minus sign is like a knife. It's going to cut
open our ellipse. And then we're going to pivot these two halves outward. These
two points will become the vertices of two branches that will face this way and
this way. So notice, I'm going to take off my ellipse now and graph my
hyperbola. Notice how the branches of this hyperbola approach the diagonals
from the rectangle. The same is true for this branch. The ins of the graph
approach the dash line, and this will always be true for our hyperbola. The ins
will always stretch towards the diagonals that we created from before. Now one
other important piece of information is that the x square term comes first
here. This means that our parabola opens to the left and to the right. And you
might be wondering, how can I get a parabola to open up and open down? Well it
turns out we just have the y squared term conversed. For example if I make this
y squared term positive here and we subtract off x squared divded by 4 here
we'll have a different type of hyperbola. Since the y squared term comes first
this hyperbola will open up. And it will open down. I'm going to take this
hyperbola off for now, and then we'll start over with our basic ellipse. Now, I
could switch the order of the y squared and the x squared terms, since addition
is commutative. So, I'm just going to move it this term to the right side of
the y squared divided by 9. I notice when I make this change, I still have the
same exact ellipse as from before. We started with our center at the origin and
we went two units left and right from that center and three units vertically up
and down. This time to get this hyperbola, we'll do one thing different. We'll
still draw our box around our ellipse and we'll have the diagonals to that box.
Now we'll use these two points as the vertices for the two hyperbola branches.
They'll face this way. The subtraction sign is going to be the knife that cuts
our ellipse in half, and then the top and bottom of the ellipse will fold
outward to create our hyperbola. So taking away our ellipse, we get this as our
hyperbola. And again notice that we have the y squared term coming first, which
means the parabola opens up and it opens down. Now that you've seen a couple of
hyperbolas, try creating some on your own. Try changing the values of the
denominators and see how the hyperbolas change. Have some fun and then continue
on with the practice.